this is all we see of Yoda during this
entire section of the movie he just
feels something is wrong he doesn't do
anything that ever makes us appreciate
the character from Empire Strikes Back
the guy who told us do not try is the
least doing character in this entire
trilogy I want you to go to the Jedi
Temple it will catch them off balance
somehow they'll not feel all this evil
bull going on right now and won't detect
you when you come to slaughter all the
kids execute order 66 yes
Commander Cody doesn't stop for even one
second to ask why the Emperor looks more
like a potato than he does the Emperor
also if you remember Cody 66 is the
order the Senate defines as wiping out
the Jedi like little bitches what well
is this what Jedi is this you don't care
I don't care I don't even think Lucas
cares as long as it looks pretty Tim
Burton design this alien planet but
asked to be uncredited after he saw a
rough first cut oh no not that
Jedi I grew to love her so much oh you I
can't believe these movies actually made
me hate Yoda so much there are CG
animators out there who got tired of all
the ways they had to draw a Yoda feeling
bad about something don't ask Jedi does
not eject look I know we're going for
killing the Jedi montage here but you
are the ones who set them up to be
superhero gods so when you go to
slaughter them maybe make some of them
infraction better than regular humans in
these situations a Jesus this movie does
more to tear down the lore of how
powerful Jedi are then it does anything
else
CGI is fun it took forever to kill him
and now I'm supposed to have a boner
because Yoda killed two guys as long as
you throw the Emperor down a shaft later
all these kids deaths will be forgiven
very tragic misuse of natalie portman
wait a second ago they were letting this
asshole leave Lin some Jedi Tommy
Tomasino jumps in and starts killing
troopers and then they're trying to kill
this guy the book if I had told you at
the outset that two of the three prequel
movies would contain scenes of obi-wan
swimming underwater would you believe me
cuz I don't think it would have goodbye
Chewbacca oh so that really was
Chewbacca how did this guy get caught up
with Han Solo that goes from a war hero
on this planet to helping some asshole
smuggle stuff across the galaxy that's
some coming home right there did you
find Kenobi
no one could have survived that poll in
real life almost everyone thinks there's
at least a small chance someone could
survive a fall like that in the movies
all the bad guys are 100% sure no one
can survive a fall like that
hey there was an attack on the Jedi
Temple you could see the smoke from here
yeah that Jedi Temple getting attacked
scene was intense I heard a lot of
harrowing dialogue about it
I feel so oh this you mispronounce
pointless this lava moon's orbit is so
close to its giant ass planet I'm
surprised it hasn't burned up in the
atmosphere yet who the said yeah I
definitely need to build an outpost on
this moon I know there's something wrong
with the scene because none of these
younglings hands are detached Anakin
kills the 33 people necessary in order
to obtain orange eyes so this is how
Liberty dies a thunderous applause sorry
nothing really stupid stuck in my throat
there Carolyn for the clones to discover
the recalibration a long time it will
take roughly as long as it took you to
say that sentence so yes come another
failure here so much other reason why
obi-wan can't believe Anakin did this is
because of all the adventures they've
had off screen together that they've
merely alluded to a couple of times
meanwhile all we've seen of Anakin is a
whiny quick to anger little bastard the
emotion of the scene is lost good of the
emperor to say this in perfect view of
the security recordings use your
feelings obi-wan and find him you will
since when do what Jedi's feelings work
in these movies why doesn't obi-wan just
play the incriminating security video of
Anakin killing children for Anakin is
the father isn't he asked then again I
was distracted by all the bullshit in
the background Anakin is the father
isn't he you seriously didn't know that
already
god damn can Jedi sense or not obi-wan
leaves Padme walks toward his ship and
the next time we see them they're about
to fly to the lava planet at no point do
we see Padme making a tough decision to
say get Anakin is evil let's kill him I
don't care if I'm carrying twins that
guy is dead also I guess obi-wan didn't
search his feelings about Anakin's
whereabouts he just happened to know
someone who knew the information you
needed obi-wan brings Padme did a lava
planet for his kill of Anakin because
what could possibly go wrong
heck
breaking my heart why do we hate this
line so much it's because the badass
character Padme we saw in Phantom Menace
going around leading an assault on the
Viceroy has become a lump of
melodramatic mush let huh go do okay if
you're not with me then you're my enemy
discount what Jesus said this is what
it's all been leading towards obi-wan
fighting Anakin and it's really kind of
the letdown east of all let downs man if
only we could had some of this Yoda to
movies ago hell under this trilogy
structure it practically demanded yo to
be terrible at Yoda until way later
Yoda takes this lightning blast as if he
wasn't expecting the Emperor to be evil
or something last the Jedi ah no more
not if anything to say about it
I had good job moving you made me want
Frank Oz to shut up somehow Anakin's
robotic arm somehow isn't strong enough
to just crush Obi Wan's throat not much
but dual lightsaber duels going on right
now but I wonder the Emperor had a tough
time with mace windu during their duel
so how does he keep up with Yoda who is
flipping all around is super fast and
mostly considered to be the best Jedi up
until recently seriously how does he not
see this until the last second how did
not CEO to stop at midair and start
spinning it and then throwing it towards
it Yoda can catch the sith lightning in
his hands proving his badassery but
eventually he falls and another fall
takes him out of the action you assume
temporarily but the movie cuts back to
the Anakin obi-wan fight and basically
makes you forget that Yoda has options
to get back in the fight for example
elevators stairs the Force instead the
next time we see Yoda he's crawling
through a wiring duct as if he's totally
defeated why would the battle ever come
to this I'd rather take my chances even
if I was cornered than to jump down on a
fucking pipe hovering above lava to
fight it's completely unbelievable
a lightsaber duel could go on this long
without any lost limbs or ears or hits
apparently not being nearly epic enough
the obi-wan Anakin fight now has to
feature them falling on a large metal
thing that we have no idea what its
purposes other than the big lightsaber
fights more dramatic because Lucas only
has so many ideas
here's a hero after a near defeat
falling from the bottom of a hovering
space building into an awaiting rescue
ship driven by the handsome minority
side character in case you haven't seen
it power strikes back into Asia I must
call
failed I have I know we need a reason
why Yoda goes to Digga bah but he very
much gave up the fight with the Emperor
too soon all the cool stuff Yoda did in
the past 10 minutes forget about it
how fortunate is it that this tower
stays upright while floating down a
river of lava it's being consumed out it
my lack of interest should be beyond
obvious by now just tell me when it's
over this is supposed to be epic but it
feels like a guy who just learned
after-effects creating his own
fanfiction and sharing it on YouTube
which was found at the very year this
movie came out coincidence wait aren't
they powering their pieces of metal junk
to fly over this lava pit leave like
this is a talent that could have gotten
a lot more use over time basically this
means you can fly as long as you have a
thing underneath you
it's over Anakin I have the high ground
yep movie about superhero Jedi freaks
that can leap small buildings well now
son I'll be decided by a couple of feet
above sea level
because some soup I have the high ground
so did Darth Maul when you saw how that
turned out also even if high ground
mattered why would Anakin need to give
up in this instance can he simply drive
back to where all this started or find
another spot that dismount it was said
that you would destroy this and not join
them you're still on about that stupidly
obi-wan takes pity on his former student
and walks away before confirming his
debt for me to do Genesis medically
she's completely healthy are there
really no human doctors left in this
world
everyone here gets treated by a big hero
6 trust in Johnny von Globen for reasons
we can't explain
we are losing her it's called e she
wasn't in the original trilogy disease
Luke Padme names her kids as they exit
her womb which is simply unnatural
it's like Lucas said no one will know
who these kids are better have Padme
named them as soon as they pop out I see
Padme went to the close your eyes and
tilt your head school the movie deaths
it seems in your anger you killed uh
Darth Vader believes this also Wow lying
liars and the lies they tell isn't he
already Darth Vader does he really still
need manipulating
yes I mean no we must take them
somewhere where the Sith will not sense
that presence will take Luke to
somewhere like I don't know Anakin's old
home planet why the hell not
and what if the boy do Tatooine to his
family send him it's almost like they
forgot the guideline they set just 20
seconds earlier I will take the child
and watch over and kinda also he and I
will keep our same last names because
that pseudonym bullsh
oh my god how to commune with him I will
teach you I also teach you about
forgetting him to have protocol droids
mind wiped but not the r2 unit he'll go
on with all his memories but forget he
knew any of these people yeah this saga
would have felt incomplete without the
Padme funeral good call Jar Jar is extra
sad about his own part in the fall of
the prequels I mean Empire and they
buried her with extra hair right did you
have that wigged out the closet
somewhere already that is a ton of hair
is all set discount long distance not
actually peter cushing
he thinks construction footage of a
doomed thing will make for an exciting
ending and movie is wrong over the 147
stock isn't later still badly burned
did they ever give him anything for that
that's going to get infected touching
Alderaan baby delivering scene is
undercut by the future knowledge that
all these are people on this planet
gonna die here have a baby also Jedi
storks also Owen and Beru aged like 40
years while Luke ages 20 the next time
we see the movie prequel trilogy thinks
it's tied off all the loose ends despite
ending roughly 20 years from the start
of the original trilogy what about
Luke's puberty what about Leia struggle
with why her parents castle has a bone
room but never has any balls also Risa
posed to believe that Luke got his
double sungazing habit from his aunt and
uncle while he was two weeks old such
poetry
you
oh this is going to be easy behind us
for droids oh dear oh I have a bad
feeling about this whole don't move sis
Lords are our speciality run or
something
how did this happen we're smarter than
this who have a plan B and try not to
upset him not to worry we are still
flying half a ship another happy landing
hello there so uncivilized
I have the high ground
is he not to destroy the Sith and bring
balance to the force
what's in your pocket but on my way I'm
gonna be doing this if you get hit it's
your own fault
Anakin all I want is your love all you
need is love my name is Inigo Montoya
you killed my father prepare to die
gentlemen we can rebuild him we have the
technology there's a man out there are
they calling during the war you know the
book the pilots woman's
it's running a little hot hold me like
you did by the lake on Naboo let's do
what we did in Mexico City
this is Buffett dragon I want this
mission hi in time I want to be home for
dinner the waters over the boys over
serve the war is over they taste like
burning hay I was dealing with this Jedi
slime myself you fool deliver the device
to me or I will destroy your ship